jb let's get into it i love your look
you look like the first
person i would see after i die i really
do think that if i
yeah i would be very happy if after i
died and left this earth
if i saw you i'd be very happy that that
means
that there's going to be a race now one
of us got to go first
and and you know that dude you putting
see
that's what we mean for you it's gonna
be
me i gotta go before you i'm not gonna
sit here and allow you to do the number
system on me
and get rid of me before you show up
you did that you did that no i didn't
mean i wanted
i didn't mean i wanted you to go first i
just think that you're spiritual
how does it work if i'm there before you
get there that means i'm going before
you
no no your spirit's already there jb you
live a long time but your spirit
is so powerful that you live in the
afterlife now and greet people
oh oh oh oh so in other words
i told myself kill my clone off
and sell my clone there first okay
you're over you're overthinking this i
don't know
how i'm digging it there in the physical
form
that means you got to kill my clone off
or
i'll kill or i go first okay leave my
hologram around here
to do stuff okay that ain't cool because
all right holograms you can see through
them a hologram can't take money because
the money gonna fall through his hands
you can't put money in his pocket he
can't hug people he's pouring through
you i know holograms do
okay you can't see a hologram i'm sorry
i didn't realize i should have known
that all i was going to do was pay you a
simple compliment
you look like a spiritual leader in the
afterlife and of course within seconds
you're yelling at me and you're offended
i'm going to tell them
the numbers out that nothing makes sense
okay
anyway i do these amazing guided
meditations called leon's god of
meditation you could hit it up on my uh
instagram or whatever or
leon's guided meditations i'm gonna
check that out let me it might help you
it might help you out
what's your spirit animal you know what
i mean i'm giving you a little bit right
now
your spirit animal would be a giraffe
because you got long-ass legs
and a long-ass neck see see so your
spirit animal
is a giraffe right now if i'm god if i'm
going to get a meditation i would say
corny stand with your legs completely
outward put your long-ass neck down
into a bowl of water and you lick that
water
you lift that water but your legs your
legs should be
straight out like and you're doing a
split but you're like maybe five
inches from the ground and you put your
long-ass neck down
and you drink the water okay i i don't
know if you were really smart
you would drink that water but you
already but you got a lemon in your
pocket
and a pack of sugar so now you turn that
lake
into lemonade see that's nice these are
the
kind of metal that's the kind of god of
meditation you need right term
lake water it's a lemonade okay okay
listen listen you are firing on all
cylinders
jb which makes me ask i want to ask you
how are you dealing in quarantine
what's gb smoove doing to keep it all
keep it all copacetic in quarantine you
know what i'm doing right now
what i do these thousand piece puzzles
oh
but i'm so good at it i mean i solve a
thousand piece puzzle
in a few hours it's done it's done
whether it's a landscape or some kind of
kind of forest or some flowers or some
animal seed i solve it i find all the
corn pieces first
and it's solved i'm that good but what i
did i challenged myself
you know what i did right i got five
boxes of thousand piece puzzles and now
it's a 5 000 piece puzzle that's a lot
of pieces
that's a lot it's not even the same
puzzle it's five different puzzles
hey you put them all together you make
five scenes it's five scenes now
how's that going terrible you know how
hard it is
you know how hard it is to do 5 000
pieces it's a mess
it's a freaking mess it's kind of like
when you go in those restaurants
you go to those country restaurants and
they got peanut shells on the floor
they allow you to eat the peanuts and
you just crack the shells
and throw the shells on the floor just
like that
and i had a whole like a whole 5 000
piece puzzle
all over the damn floor now by roomba i
had the roomba
the rumors are all confused they don't
know whether to pick up the damn
the pickup vacuum the damn puzzle
or leave it alone we don't know well the
roomba isn't rumba's just going to pick
up anything roomba's not supposed to
make those decisions
i'm telling you i'm that's what i'm
trying to tell you i don't know if the
the missing pieces are in the room but
i'm not i don't know all right
i'm trying to figure this out okay well
and that takes me out of my zen
i'm completely out of my zen right now i
don't know what in the room
jb i don't think you're ever in a zen
moment my sense is that you are never
zen
every time i talk to you you're worked
up about something
you are never zen for a second in my
opinion i'm just telling you
you don't know what's in it see you're a
giraffe
you are you're a goofy-ass giraffe and
that's your fault for not being in my
zen
you would stand your zen you stay with
within your spirit animal
okay okay cause you already shook me to
heaven without you
okay i'm sorry you got me all messed up
now
i don't know what's gonna happen now
well wait a minute i'll ask you
something what's your spirit animal you
said i'm a goofy ass giraffe what are
you
come on man everybody knows what i am
man i'm something plain and simple man
i'm a gazelle baby i'm a straight
gazelle because you know
i'm i'm i'm fast i'm nimble
but at the same time when i'm when i'm
when i'm still when i'm
when i'm still and i'm in the i'm
looking around watching the predators
when i see a predator i'm going i'm
going i'm freaking
i'm fast you hear me yeah i jump
i run i jump i run i jump see
i run you know i got a leap over
obstacles and obstacles
obstacles are life that's life you know
how hard it is for you
being a giraffe if a predator comes and
you're wearing them damn
goofy as high-heeled shoes and your
long-ass neck and your stupid-ass legs
huh you know how hard it is and on
bushy-ass eyelashes
you know how hard it is for you to get
away from the predator yeah yeah you
know how hard it is
yeah that ain't that like that can't be
easy walking around that's a goddamn
good
giraffe okay no it's not i've never
escaped a predator in my life they get
me
people go on little excursions and
little uh
those little those little safari big ass
head through the window all the time
you're putting a big ass head through
the window huh they're like getting
out of here giraffe like headed in the
damn see
that's it that's exactly what you're
doing right there all right
your neck comes through the window see
you looking around trying to find snacks